good morning everybody good day my name
is jeff phipps
we're going to talk about uh how to
equitably close the cs education gap
thank you strangeloo for having me i
grabbed their logo and put it on my
slide so we'll start with there
let's start with introductions my
twitter handle is at uh teals jeffrey
j-e-f-f-e-r-y
there's a not so funny story on why my
name is spelled weird than everybody
else spells it but legally it is rei but
uh it's ery anymore so i am the st louis
regional manager of the teals program i
taught high school uh math and computer
science here in st louis at a st louis
public school district at a school
called central visual and performing
arts high school for 13 years
uh i joined the microsoft philanthropies
teals program one year ago
and uh i do enjoy python in
java coding challenges but i am not a
software engineer nor i have ever been i
came into this uh from a high school
perspective and maybe i can help uh
explain to you why we need uh what we
need what i'm gonna get to so uh
let's go around the room real quick do
some introductions uh if blake if you'd
start me out just kind of tell me who
you are and what you do
we'll go through this as quickly as
possible and then we'll get on to the
big thing so
great so most all of us here are
software engineers
uh how many of us saw computer science
before college
okay a majority of the room i learned
how to code at seventh grade believe it
or not and we had a basic i learned on
apple 2gs anybody learned
younger older than that
all right handful of people tandy's
around the same time the apple 2e2 gs
that's where i learned basic
in seventh grade and i saw it again in
10th grade okay
we have a problem
and i say we i mean all of us okay
we have a gap in computer science
education so a lot of us in this room
saw computer science in high school said
hey this is something i can do we went
on we studied computer science in high
school i do have a minor in computer
science but again i became a high school
math teacher all right so i did use that
knowledge that i had in high school
and i applied it to
college and i thought i wanted to code
until i started coding and i realized i
don't like coding
and i don't i don't want to be a
software engineer and i was like but i
like math too and i want to i want to
solve a problem me personally and the
problem i wanted to solve is i wanted to
help at-risk kids i wanted to reach
people that didn't have those things and
that's why i chose to teach in the city
okay so i made a conscious effort to
teach math in in the science computer
science came up and that's how i ended
up here uh at the teals program
67
of all jobs are in computing there's 400
000 current openings all of you you
stood up and you said hey
we're hiring how many people here are
hiring
right now
the majority of the room is hiring right
now
uh so we have a problem
and at teals we're going to try and help
fix it 47 schools right now we're at 50
in missouri state of missouri it's a
little bit higher arkansas is at 60
right now and they're number one in the
united states i would have never made
that guess but maybe because of walmart
who knows
in 2016 only 75 individuals graduated
from universities equipped to teach
computer science compared to 12 000 math
teachers
so what is the teal's program all right
some of you come by and visit the booth
thank you you got my card we gave away
cool pens uh we had those bracelets too
that charge your phone uh please come by
if you haven't and grab those before the
end of the day um
what it stands for is technology
education and literacy in schools and
right now we're trying to help compete
high schools
uh develop a computer science track so
that for the people who are in here that
saw it uh you know beforehand before
they got to college that we can reach
those people all right
we help here's how our program works we
identify teachers and we identify
schools that do not have computer
science and we work at industry
volunteers such as you all
like blake here who uh will uh share
along his message blake volunteers at a
school called st mary's here in st louis
that uh is about 50 african american um
and he goes to the class twice a week
and he helps volunteer and he's helping
christine the classroom teacher become a
computer science teacher so that after
two or three years
christine is independent
and then we move on to another school
and we help set up their computer
science track okay
we focus on engaging students uh
excluded from learning computer science
because of race gender and geography so
that includes rural schools we remote
into schools there's a school in
lebanon missouri which is uh i think 300
people
and right now they're learning computer
science a which is a java class anybody
take that in high school
computer science a one two people uh
where they're learning object oriented
programming right now
okay and then again if you see it early
the earlier you see it the more likely
that you realize that this is a path
that you can take
and like i said we're looking for for
looking for people right
okay so here's my ask here's why i'm
here somebody asked me that directly uh
this week why are you here if you're
worried about high schools uh why are
you here well i'll tell you why our
volunteers help fill the subject matter
gaps
uh for teachers and provide support
through the year as questions arise okay
so these teachers know how to teach but
we're going to teach them computer
science and then that way the gap is
closed all right the volunteers make uh
impacts multiple times not only do these
kids so like we have volunteers from
like riot games
these kids get to see like oh i can make
video games i could work there uh we
have volunteers from launch code we have
volunteers from all over the industry
and so the kids actually get to see they
get to understand what
you do with a computer science degree
okay our volunteers expand their career
horizons like i said
uh only 45 percent of students
say an adult has encouraged them to
pursue a computer science degree now i'm
sure here it'd be much higher but just
think about in general did anybody
before you can study computer science
say hey computer science is for you
okay
so here's where we're at this is for the
2021 school year uh the next time i give
this presentation it will be updated
we're uh we're in 455 schools as of last
year including 27 states and british
columbia cambia canada
and we recently uh opened up some
schools in juarez mexico so we are
expanding our reach throughout the north
america we do about 589 computer science
classes we're reaching about 12
12 000 students and 35 percent of them
are female
we are expanding so recently we've gone
to uh new orleans we're in jacksonville
we're in memphis we are expanding our
reach
and we are trying to grow so right now
we're probably in about six or seven
hundred schools
my numbers aren't going to be accurate
we have about 12 uh 2 000 volunteers
so part of microsoft's commitment to the
black and african-american community
is that we're expanding our reach so
we're part of what we call the black and
african-american expansion we're working
with schools to strategize and re uh our
resources to help increase uh equitable
participation in high school computer
science and we're creating an action
plan and implementing it to make
progress towards diversity inclusion
outcomes there's a reason why i'm here
in st louis
so i've been working with school
districts like jennings if you're
familiar with the st louis area which is
a 98 african-american student uh mac
here is from the ferguson florist in
school district
which again has a similar demographic
where it's about 90 african american
students so we are making a committed
effort to help reach
school districts where again
if you don't hear computer computer
science is a thing you don't think about
it
all right
so you can help that's why i'm here
i need help
we need help these teachers need help
all right 48 percent of students see
themselves taking studying computer
science more after having a computer
science class 58 of them study think
that they can study computer science
afterwards and 91 of these students see
themselves going to college all right if
you expand a student's horizons you make
all the difference in the world and i
cannot emphasize that enough all right i
mean i could say it's blue in the face i
know as a former teacher like
there were kids who saw saw themselves
not making what they were doing and then
they went into engineering they went
into you know mathematics they went to
like i had a student take actuarial
science which is just i felt bad for her
but that's what she wanted to do
i'm like i don't know why anybody would
want to do that for a living but god
bless you um
we set you up for success so let's say
so our volunteer application opens up in
january
um and we get you ready for that so we
uh you uh you apply we'll interview you
we'll see where you're a good fit and
here's what we do we volunteer we train
you over the summer all right your
teaching team will meet throughout the
summer to build cohesion and plan for
the year
we have classroom observations and
feedback as a matter of fact i came and
saw blake and mack earlier in the last
two weeks and i provided feedback to
both of them and told them you know gave
them opportunities to grow and stuff
like that there are multiple
opportunities to share with people
within your community okay so we have
meetups where you meet other volunteers
and stuff like that so you can expand
your network and then there's a
dedicated regional manager to answer
your questions and provide support if
you're in the st louis area or in the
state of missouri uh you'd be dealing
with me directly and i'm not the worst
person to deal with
right
okay thank you
[Laughter]
okay
so you're saying to yourself uh all
right i reached out uh i'm in uh so
somebody was just talking to me from
nashville a minute ago um
we don't have schools in nashville
and like i said we have a school in
lebanon missouri which is in the middle
of nowhere in the ozarks you can work
from home and also if you know during
the pandemic you can still remote in
from home max volunteers for example one
of them is chicago and the other one is
at champaign illinois
and so they come in and they zoom in
twice a week or once a week right now
and they help the class out through zoom
we are agnostic so i know the question
gets asked i'll go ahead and address it
now we are part of the microsoft
philanthropies program we're not going
to push anything microsoft related on
you uh we do not ask that you become the
school becomes a microsoft school we do
not ask we do not need you to be a
microsoft employee we just need you to
be committed to helping grow computer
science all right so this is part of the
community outreach program at microsoft
and that's what i do so i'm a part of
philanthropies i'm not a part of
microsoft
proper i guess you'd say but not really
but i am so
but we do provide on virtual support so
this guy is out of kansas city and he
helps schools uh out in rural texas
and that's what he does
and that's what he likes to do and
that's what he does as a volunteer so if
you're in the bay area and you want to
help somewhere else we could gladly help
accommodate that
all right so i'm going to show you a
little video real quick on what remote
uh volunteering looks like hopefully we
tested the sound earlier right greg
we're good to go so let's watch a video
real quick where uh some of our
volunteers talk about what it was like
teaching during the pandemic when i was
in high school nobody told me that you
could make a career out of computer
science or coding and that was a huge
factor for me in becoming involved with
teals volunteering remotely because i
wish i had that person in my life
volunteering remotely makes just as much
different as volunteering in person
you're going to bring all that knowledge
to the table and share that knowledge
with the students and knowledge is power
[Music]
a typical day when i teach with teals is
i follow my normal routine i get coffee
and then i sit down at my desk which is
right next to my bed because i'm working
in my bedroom and then i go right to
teaching i just log onto the website and
i click into my class and i'm pulled up
into a virtual classroom the first 15
minutes or so it will be a lecture
portion led by volunteers or a classroom
teacher and then the last 30 to 40
minutes will be actually breakout room
sessions where we go and work with the
students individually or in groups i
know i was a little unsure
but open to volunteering virtually but
that is just the best feeling in the
world to be able to help somebody to
gather the knowledge and the confidence
to learn computer science
i think that the opportunity to give
these kids this background and
understanding in computer science is
going to open doors for them that would
have never been open without the support
of teals and
if you take the time and you put in the
effort it's really easy to connect with
students on a more personal level
working in small breakout rooms i think
is a lot more inviting for students it
makes us as instructors a lot more
accessible to the students and i have to
say that's pretty important because the
kids get a lot of really close attention
and are able to receive the the support
that they need ultimately the tl's model
is that we want to support the teacher
and the school so that they are able to
be self-sufficient in the future so as a
teals volunteer it is a very
collaborative partnership with our
teacher our teacher is the lead of the
classroom from an instructional
standpoint and from a classroom
management standpoint we got you covered
the teacher will provide you with that
support that you need anybody that's
programming
really has a great opportunity to make
an impact on society and in your
community just giving a couple hours a
week is gonna be so impactful for the
teacher the student the school i think
it's just such a great opportunity for
students to actually have a career that
can not only change their life but it
can impact generations to come when we
work with students we hold a lot more
power than we think we do those students
can change the world but if they don't
have someone tell them that they might
not believe it
[Music]
okay so here's what your actual week
would look like we do actually make it
ask a commitment that you come to the
classroom twice a week however not every
volunteer does it just depends on the
program
but we ask that it's a five hour a week
commitment usually like one hour in the
classroom twice a week and then we ask
that your team meets once a week
to prepare for the week ahead all right
so you'd read lesson plans adapt your
activities you collaborate with your
teaching team you'll discuss you know
how students are doing what you could do
better stuff like that
you uh volunteered the one thing that we
one we asked our schools a couple things
one that they cover all the recruit the
involvement in the costs so like you're
and now there's nothing out of pocket
for you the school will cover your
background check so that'll be taken
care of and then
uh we ask that they make computer
science the first class in the morning
so our ask is that computer science is
done by 9 30 a.m so that you know if
you're a late goer or something like
that you go in after after that
um or you know for some places we may
you know we ask that you make
arrangements like you know hey tell your
bosses is what you're doing
i've only seen one person so far in my
uh my year
say that their boss told them no
for the most part i think your your boss
is going to be pretty acceptable that
you're volunteering your time
at a high school to help improve
computer science
okay
we are an industry-wide effort like i
said uh we are part of microsoft but we
are we pull our volunteers from
everywhere we're over in over 650
companies we have about 1500 like i said
right now we have about 2 000 because
this is last year's slide and we reach
about 12 000 students here are some of
the companies that we work with
amazon facebook google uh lyft uber uh
riot games we met with them we have a
handful of them from great games
but we have volunteers from everywhere
all right not just microsoft
which is like one of our bigger
suppliers obviously
all right so
what would you support i'm glad you
asked uh we support four main core
classes
for the most part but that fourth one
covers a lot of topics the first one is
an introduction to computer science
usually those are block based
programming
and python is usually the language that
people use to introduce computer science
to people
those are curriculums such as cmu
targeted melon university has one
project lead the way code.org
like cs essentials cs discoveries you'll
see the names of those the second one is
computer science principles which is a
year-long ap course that teaches the
internet again that one is language
agnostic so you might see python you
might see java you might see a handful
of javascript some of them again
code.org is one we support microsoft has
one
there are several others that i'm just
blanking on right now popfiz is a newer
one that's providing one project lead
the way and then there's ap computer
science a which is a full
that semester that first semester of
object-oriented program that you had
it's in java specifically it's run by
the ap
and so
that one is very uh very rigid and
structured some of the curriculum
providers are uh cs awesome
um bjc uh cargo melon again we have our
own uh curriculum that's on github that
you can look at if you want to take a
look at the curriculum um and then the
last one are computer science topics
this is like cyber security game design
and machine learning that we're
implementing in schools not a lot of
schools add these so we don't we try to
support them where we can but this is
like this is where it's going but these
first three are our big core
um and then like some schools are adding
these extra ones and then we try and
support them where we can
volunteering's beneficial all right 91
of our volunteers have found the
experience rewarding we have about a 60
retention rate or so
like i said you connect and collaborate
with like-minded individuals you become
more integrated in that local community
at that school you're in
and you create a lasting relationship
with teachers and stuff like that blake
has been a volunteer for four years in a
minute we're going to let him we're
going to let you guys ask questions and
he can tell you how much that's made an
impact in his life
all right so who are we looking for so
uh you know i've kind of explained the
program pretty well
here's our target demographic if you're
a cs graduate if you're an industry
professional in a cs related role and if
you're a junior or senior who's like
high achieving we're looking for you
all right if you have a coding
background if you understand concepts
like wow loop if uh functions return
values stuff like that
you're ready like uh
so we need you
you can apply your knowledge and
experience and ignite interest for
computer science students uh throughout
the united states
but maybe it isn't for you maybe you've
sat and you've heard me and you're like
okay uh this sounds amazing i like what
you're doing
i'm not doing it
there's nothing wrong with that
all right it's not for everyone we're
literally asking you to make a school
year commitment that is a big deal and
twice a week at that so that's a lot of
time that's a lot of your time i get
that all right but you can certainly
spread the word if you've never heard of
our program before and you know people
who want to get back into their
communities this is one way they can do
it
all right if you have like if you're uh
like the the the ceo or if you're part
of that that tech you know if you're a
senior tech person we would love to come
and talk to your company and look for
volunteers that way like at worldwide
tech last year we gave a i don't know if
you remember that or if you saw it we
were there i presented pretty much the
same uh the same thing then
but we presented it riot games we
presented at microsoft we presented
companies throughout the united states
and just you know we're looking for help
and you know
you can spread the word like i said you
can share with someone who may be
interested in our program
you know hey i would love to give back
okay well hey i heard of this program
called teals and they're great
all right
i'm gonna leave with this one last
example okay this is joe bell he's out
of detroit michigan
jovel was almost like a high school
dropout
all right and he was at an alternative
school
and we have teals there and they had
computer science
and uh jovel took to it like a fish
takes to water
jovel started coming into school early
to code started getting ahead of the
teacher on the programs
jovel had a summer landed a summer
internship and he is now working towards
being a software developer uh recently i
don't know if anybody follows uh on the
linkedin
we have a big uh
he's one of our showcases right now on
our linkedin site so if you go to uh you
just type in microsoft heals on linkedin
you'll see a big thing about uh jovel
he's amazing
all right and again did not know that
coding existed and just kind of happened
to discover it and then just took right
to it like probably a lot of you in this
room right like you just kind of started
with it and all of a sudden it's like
this is this is who i am i love coding
all right
so what are the next steps
uh you can apply online the application
will open this spring our website is
microsoft.com teals
if you have any questions whatsoever
my email address again remember it's ery
not rei it's a jeff ery you can get a
card at the table where you have a booth
get yourself a pen at least
we've got some cool pens with like
little fuzzy heads on them they're
pretty interesting to get one of those
you can reach out to me on twitter at
tealsgeoffrey you can reach out to me on
linkedin i'm jeffrey phipps on linkedin
uh there's eight million ways to get a
hold of me i would love to answer any of
your questions and like i said i spoke
to some of you and you said you were in
the bay area or if you're uh here or
there i will put you in touch with the
person in your region all right
um
it helped us spread the word like i said
thank you so much
um you can learn more at microsoft.com
you can also hit us up at aka.ms slash
teals contact and that's where you fill
out like the information form and that
will actually direct you directly to the
person that'll do that
all right so before we close out before
i say thank you i'd like to bring up uh
mac and blake here if you would please
and i'm going to let you ask them
questions blake mills is a four-year
volunteer and mac is in her
in their first year
as a teacher
with the program
so
i will let you fire away and ask
questions and hopefully we can help get
some clarity here
we don't select schools they apply for
us so our application is actually
opening up in 15 days on the 15th
um right now we're getting ready for uh
recruiting settings so i will go look
for schools like uh that's part of my
job i try to recruit schools like
ferguson florist it was a school
district that i uh apply like i bugged
there's no other better way to say it
i emailed them i told them about our
program uh you know got a hold of the
right person and then they applied and
then we accepted them as a school so if
you know of a school or like you know
your kid doesn't have computer science
at their school
have them reach out to us
through the contact information they can
submit their form we can contact them
and then we can kind of go from there
yeah but i mean that's
so that's that's a great question and
that's that's like a that is a problem
right
we reach out to schools
i like uh so like last year i reached
out to st louis public school district i
reached out to ferguson florissant i
reached out to east st louis
so if you're are you from st louis
okay so like
i reach out personally to schools
someone like you could let these schools
know that we exist and then they can
reach out to us wherever there is a
demand that's where we put a regional
manager so like we don't have a utah
person right now but we have like a
northern california person
who also works in oregon and so that
person would probably be the person to
help set that up and get that started
but um you know sometimes schools just
hear of us like randomly or haphazardly
but we do make an effort to try and
reach out to schools and get their
attention
questions did that answer your question
okay oh no problem
anybody else
um i know amazon has the future
engineers program where they're kind of
doing a similar thing i know apple has
one but i don't know the name of it off
the top of my head i just stumbled
across it because they were looking for
a st louis person
um
but i know there are other companies
doing this thing as far as like other
countries
um
basically juarez organized itself and
then we rubber stamped it does that make
sense and british columbia was almost
the same situation but then they had so
many people in british columbia that we
sent a regional manager there
um
in terms of other companies that do
these kind of things not off the top of
my head
i'm kind of living in you know my own
little bubble where i've got to deal
with like st louis and missouri and
stuff like that but there certainly are
as far as like other countries like i
don't know who i don't know where you
would go to find out who does that kind
of stuff
i mean there can be depending on the
school
i mean for csa they ask that you take
algebra 2
usually but for like computer science
principles ap designed that course just
to be an introductory course for like
even for teachers who had no background
the way the reason why they created
computer science principles was to
create more high school computer science
teachers so their assumption is that a
the teacher doesn't have much of a
background in computer science and b the
students don't have a background in
computer science computer science
principles is almost like an
introductory class in itself except it's
a little more rigorous
anybody have any questions for blake or
uh mac why they're here
hello uh when a student says oh i can
see myself being a programmer now when
they hadn't thought about it before
or when they just do one thing you ask
them to because sometimes that that's a
battle
i feel i feel very uh
hurt by that last comment um
we've just started this this year i
would say
um
[Music]
i kind of i shared with jeff yesterday
but uh we had a really cool moment the
other day where
the students jump on the zoom the
volunteers are there and
we had started up a lesson the previous
class and and so i was like well you
know the volunteers need to know where
we're at in our lesson
and so i was like okay well you know who
wants to share it with them i did bribe
them with candy because you know it's
you know almost halloween and all that
but anyway so i was like hey two pieces
of candy if you'll jump on the zoom and
and share your screen and explain your
program and it was just a really great
moment where
the students were like yeah okay and
they're they were i mean they were
secretly excited about it they probably
would have done it without the candy but
um but yeah and then it was great
because the volunteers asked questions
that they really needed to know the
answer to to try to help
um and
but but it was a really great moment
where the teacher i mean the student was
now the teacher you know and that's i
love that flip classroom classroom kind
of thing or whatever and it's just a
great interaction for them to have
another adult
that's you know coaching them and
guiding them and and it just really
fosters like a learning community vibe
that i really try to make in my
classroom where it's like i'm not like
the leader like we're in a learning
community and we're all learning and
growing together and and i think having
the the
other coaches volunteers
just really
makes that even more um
more more of a real life kind of
experience for them
anybody else
yeah
yeah that's a great question so we do
two different models usually we have a
slide for this and i guess we didn't for
this one um
we have what they call a co-teach model
so that's like we have a team of four
volunteers come in uh two of them will
actually lead the class in in teaching
and the other two will be the tech
support or like lab support for this
teacher for those co-teachers while the
teacher like and that's the assumption
is that a teacher has like no background
in computer science um usually a school
will do that for one to two years and
then they'll uh or they'll start at our
lab support model where we'll have two
volunteers come in and they'll so
they'll teach so for most of our teams
like um
blake has a person uh who's remote his
name is ed and ed come was it lived in
st louis who got promoted and he comes
in from chicago
uh zooms in and he helps uh when the
days that blake's not there so they they
have so yeah you won't be alone in
isolation now uh michael who's up at the
booth right now he is alone in his thing
but they're a very unique situation
where
we don't really need to support them at
their point their teacher is amazing
already gets has like a really good
grasp of computer science and his kids
go to that school
so we're basically like
yeah yeah michael you can help your you
can help your school we'll we'll we'll
stamp it and we'll be like you can say
your teal school but for real you're not
really a teal school like we're trying
to you're trying to reach like you know
schools where the teachers are like are
ramping up
and so we yeah our teams are usually two
to four people
any other questions yes
uh
yeah after about one blake in st louis i
think i was pretty much done with it but
um do you go by anything else besides
blake
okay
no uh there's no limit on names um
unless it breaks the system we had three
people named the same thing i guess i
don't know i i assume we just start
going by middle initials at that point
uh any other questions
yes
what's that can you speak up
uh well i mean we're limited by the
number of schools we have and we're
limited by uh location and regions so
like for example
sometimes we'll need volunteers in
detroit and we don't have anybody in
detroit so we'll have to remote in we
won't have you know like so basically
like at the
at the summer i was still looking for
people in st louis um right now i'm
still technically looking for one person
because we had a tragic accident with uh
one of our volunteers i don't know if
anybody in here knew zack schneider
he recently passed away he was in a
train derailment
and he was from fairview heights he was
volunteering at jennings
okay and
so we lost him and so now i'm trying to
find a in-person
co-teacher for that python class so if
you're in front of st louis and you're
you know volunteer and you're interested
uh come see me because i really need to
volunteer for that school um
but so that happens so we do sometimes
need volunteers so the best thing you
can do is fill out the contact
information if you're ready to go now
maybe we have an opening somewhere like
we probably do have openings but they're
very like unique situations does that
make sense basically we're talking about
for january is when our volunteer
application opens up and we're going to
be looking people for to start that next
school year you have a question in the
back
the what
[Music]
yes it can be in person
yeah i don't know if i made that clear
or not but most of it like blake's in
person uh but his co is support person
is remote her volunteers are their
volunteers are remote and um
so it just depends on the situation but
like jennings those people are in person
um a lot of my schools here in st louis
are in person but because of like the
unique situation with ed uh ed went to
saint mary's and so he still wants to
get back to st mary's but ed got
promoted and moved to chicago so
so ed zooms in so it just depends on the
situation a lot of our schools are in
person this year i would anticipate next
year most of our schools being in person
because i think
fingers crossed that we come to some
kind of understanding that we just have
to kind of get back to normal whatever
normal is
does that make sense and that's just a
personal opinion that has nothing to do
with anything related to deal situation
or anything like that i just want to
throw out the disclaimer
but i i think most of them will be in
person next year personal opinion any
other questions
all right well thank you very much for
having me
please if you have any questions on the
way out
hit up mac hit up blake hit up myself
i'd love to talk to you again we have a
booth over by the john deere thing so
when you get done playing with the
tractor come by get a pen maybe get my
card ask me questions and maybe some of
you will be helping us out next year and
that would be great thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
you